as this builds let me prepare you for
what's about to come this motivation man
there's me helping you helping myself so
I had a bagel with words of wisdom from
somebody who has none whatsoever I'm
going to take my morning constitutional
with my dogs well with my one dog and I
want to show you what anticipation looks
like I want to show you how you should
greet every task of every day even the
[ __ ] you don't want to do man the
enthusiasm that this dog has for this
walk we're about to take is how you need
to basically go every every day or life
man keep some in my connections weak
you're weak
let me see hey I'll be back in one
second make sure now that says my
connections good [ __ ] it
ok ready for this this is passion
hey you ready go out for a walk you
ready to do this you ready to go okay I
think you don't even know I don't even
need to do my job I'm so [ __ ] excited
oh boy oh boy Joe man show me yeah I'm
[ __ ] terrified ostrich other yeah at
our church
he's got no [ __ ] business standing
doing you and I walk quite that bad oh
I'm dead bitingly happy man yeah I'm
[ __ ] can't wait to do my [ __ ]
thing whatever my thing is I'm gonna
scratch the [ __ ] bird until what
comes I'm a point to [ __ ] under this bed
I'm been partly excited to get going
don't look at me like I'm crazy you're
one bite in a [ __ ] bed did you give
me funny me
she's right I'm making fun of her but
that's how you gotta greet every day man
and every test look she's back I have it
holy [ __ ] what I mean she gave me these
big until whatever I want happens that's
not the lesson here the lesson here is
not bite the [ __ ] bed the lesson is
never given look at this [ __ ] even know
what the lesson is how far you can drag
that bed now I'm kind of fascinated by
that all right the lesson is little
things are very [ __ ] strong
the lesson is little things can only
take a [ __ ] big dog bed only so far
all right man she's not doing anything
interesting
well she's like I'm on it [ __ ] you big
boy
I'll show you interesting I could move
four times my body weight I'm a goddamn
champion dead bitin [ __ ] a champion all
ain't no and some good happens but
that's how you got approached today see
just like that little dog back there man
bed bitingly happy to [ __ ] do whatever
it is you're gonna do look at her holy
[ __ ] she's lifting it up man she's
lifting up the mattress that thing's
gotta be like at least four times bigger
than her see I don't know what the
lesson is there but we'll figure it out
together in any event last night I was
on the talking dead and had a good time
tomorrow night my episode of the flash
that's me runnin fest is on it's called
killer frost and it's it's I like it
it's it's pretty dope it's it's danielle
panabaker place Caitlyn gets to go like
apeshit crazy and act and choose
sceneries wonderful stuff so watch that
and also tomorrow yoga hosers is out on
iTunes and on blu-ray DVD if there are
people out there still spending DVDs it
comes out tomorrow and those formats get
to see them and stuff
so I'll talk about that more tomorrow
but again man lesson for today today's
motivation you're sitting there going I
want things I want to accomplish things
I want to do this I want to be like this
[ __ ] or that [ __ ] number one don't
ever want to be like some other [ __ ]
want to be like you and then figure out
how to get paid to be you and do the
things that you would do anyway not for
free or for free but then try get paid
for it that's the secret to life or a to
the American Way I don't know I'm not
I'm not quite sure
secret changes all the time right but
that's that's been a healthy attitude
for me man like don't look to somebody
else and be like oh I want to do what
they're doing why them one at me that
why them why not me thing is the [ __ ]
very few love the Internet but it's kind
of a waste of time why then why not you
because you're sitting there wondering
why that why not you you know how them
got to where you want to be
they never sat around and said why then
why not me that's a [ __ ] Payton waste
of time and basically you need to you
need to be creating the future you want
man there's this thing of read an
article once that said the we always
think the future version of ourselves
gonna be way better than the present
version of ourselves like oh [ __ ] we
go to a grocery store this is the
example they use and you buy vegetables
because you're like this week I'm gonna
eat vegetables for a change man and so
you think all right [ __ ] I'm gonna do
it you buy the [ __ ] ton of vegetables
and then what do you do you don't eat
the vegetables man they rot in the
crisper another week goes by and [ __ ]
and you're still not the vegetable
eating [ __ ] you thought you
would be that's because you're still you
at the end of the day man
like that's can't really sit there and
be like I'm gonna be better next week
because you are you next week you know
how you get better next week you build a
perfect foolproof version of the future
so that your present self just has to
step into it doesn't have to make any
[ __ ] big choices because you're you
you know you're not gonna make any big
choices but if you build the thing now
presents you builds the thing for future
you and makes it [ __ ] foolproof and
stuff then even an idiot like past you
which is technically present you can't
[ __ ] it up see it's that simple man
present you needs to build the future
you can't expect future you to be
smarter than present you present smart
future you depends on present you this
is getting a little [ __ ] back to the
future soon we'll need a Polaroid with
people disappearing and somebody's gonna
want to [ __ ] their mother without
knowing it but seriously build your
future now whatever you want to be a
even a week from now you have to start
doing today because the future version
of you
never gonna do it unless the present
version of you starts let's hear that
bill that is a paradox maybe but [ __ ]
shakers like [ __ ] your paradox so let's
go out on a [ __ ] walk let's check
back in on the dog you ready for this my
friend oh my god you moved the whole
[ __ ] bed look at you I'm mighty
[ __ ] I'm mighty present me he
wants to get the [ __ ] out of this house
and take shits in the wire I meant show
me where the door is
show me where the doors are so smart did
you or did you the door
[ __ ] I'm excited I'm off to the races go
ahead I'm coming that's where I'm not
[ __ ] room much smarter you were I'm
much smarter than she is I outwitted
that [ __ ] dog
I used my [ __ ] mind you know how that
worked out past keV setup future keV to
defeat the mind of that tiny little dog
and once again man is mightier than
beasts
and that is today's motivation no not at
all look how smart you just came right
back up looking for me
alright I'm gonna go walk the dog man
maybe I'll check in may be not the
signals that that's strong on the hill
but remember whatever you want
begins today this moment right now you
have to start building it nobody's ever
gonna give it to you nobody ever got
their [ __ ] life handed to him nobody
except Hal Jordan they gave him a magic
ring and they were like you're the
[ __ ] guardian of this sector
[ __ ] so we can't all be Hal
Jordan and [ __ ] but if we train very
hard we can be like Batman especially if
you got a lot of money and [ __ ] and if
your parents are dead you know what
don't be like those people they're sad
be like you that was the [ __ ] smote
ovation Ubu could have heard that on the
internet kids say it all the time but
sometimes you need saying it from
another dude who's middle-aged and
should all right there it is man I'm
about to lose this dog look at her
I'm so patient I'm so [ __ ] patient
then self-love and piece of [ __ ] all
right I'm out of here man it's
motivation number one for today come
back tomorrow give a little more some
motivation